with his top team around him this was
president biden's latest attempt to
convince america and the world that he
has a handle on a crisis that was of his
making since i spoke to you on monday
we've made significant progress
it was a moment for concrete commitments
we're going to do everything everything
that we can to provide safe evacuation
for our afghan allies
partners and afghans who who
who
might be targeted if because of their
association with the united states
but let me be clear
any american who wants to come home
we will get you home
yet on the ground in and around kabul
airport a commitment like that comes up
against reality a chaos that the us and
british soldiers are doing their best to
manage there was a commitment for them
too
and i made it clear to them that we'll
get them whatever they need to do the
job
he is a president who has pledged
repeatedly that with his leadership
america is back and yet now he's led his
allies into a crisis for them all what
is your message to the america's
partners around the world who have
criticized not the withdrawal but the
conduct of that withdrawal and made it
made them question america's credibility
on the world stage i have seen no
question of our credibility from our
allies around the world
i've spoken with our nato allies we've
spoken with nato allies
the secretary of state our national
security adviser has been in contact
with his counterparts throughout the
world and our allies as has
the general or excuse me i keep calling
them in general but my secretary of
defense the fact of the matter is i have
not seen that matter of fact the exact
opposite i've got
the reality in european capitals does
not quite match that
we went and did the mission you've known
my position for a long long time
it's time to end this war
he maintains he has done what's best for
america but what's clearer daily is the
impact internationally and most urgently
in afghanistan